women who take hormonal birth control
are priming themselves for the kind of
men that have lower testosterone it's
like the demand and the supply of the
market for this up until the point in
which they come off it it's like they
want the provisioning right like like
one a guy who's going to be a provider
but that's also Smith is driven by
testosterone you know we know that men's
testosterone levels are associated with
like mating success and all that on the
one hand but it's also associated with
achievement men who are CEOs and
presidents testosterone too it's like in
some ways we're also shooting ourselves
in the foot right it's like why aren't
there any good men around who are like
achieving things and like being
successful and maybe there has something
to do with women's sex hormones so
interesting